and this is a live look at Harry Reid
International Airport where stacks of
luggage remain unclaimed passengers are
frustrated and hundreds of flights are
canceled thanks for joining us here at
11 o'clock I'm Denise Valdez so tonight
we hear from locals who are stranded
trying to make it back home to Las Vegas
Madison Kimbrough joins us live from
Harry Reid International with one couple
story
tonight we hear from a Henderson couple
that is currently 2 000 miles away and
all they want is to make it home back to
Vegas
honestly at this point I'm so eager to
be home that I would seriously consider
a one-way car rental and just driving
across the country for however many days
it takes Adam Burke and his wife Jessica
went to South Carolina for the holidays
to visit family the plan was to return
to Vegas Monday night but like so many
Southwest Travelers they are now stuck
with the only available flight to Vegas
departing this Saturday we found a hotel
last night yeah we we re-upped our
rental car for a week we don't know what
we're staying after tonight
probably somewhere back in Colombia but
you know we had to find a hotel and
because flights on Southwest are so
limited Jessica feels the other airlines
are taking advantage of stranded
Travelers there was a flight from
Charlotte to Vegas that would have cost
us 2600 a person some of the other
airlines were really taking advantage of
Southwest kind of downfall at this point
um that's honestly what made me the
maddest and although not too far other
travelers from California are hitting
the road and ditching potential flights
all together that being the best option
for them to return home to Vegas we have
right now the ability to take a bus in
the morning I think that's going to be
what we choose it's the quickest and the
cheapest way to get back right now I'm
not looking forward to being on a bus
for five hours but four and a half
whatever it is but you know we'll get we
just need to get back
baggage claim a very busy night as you
can see here in baggage claim a very
busy night for travelers still no idea
when flights will pick back up again but
while rental car options are scarce
Amtrak train and Greyhound buses are a
potential option although tickets are
also limited reporting in Harry Reid
International Airport Madison Kimbrough
8 News Now